florence pugh confirms her split with
zach braff and tells fans to calm down
about that moment in the don't worry
darling trailer i did some acting the
marvel star reveals she and zach went
their separate ways in january florence
tells harper's bazaar we've been trying
to do this separation without the world
knowing because it's been a relationship
that everybody has an opinion on yeah
lots of opinions about the former couple
who did their best to keep their love
out of the public eye but amid their
quarantine in 2020 zack briefly bragged
about florence's hidden talent i'm
hunkering down with my girlfriend my
girlfriend's an amazing chef and i can't
cook at all over on social media the
fans were pretty vocal about their 21
year age gap she's 26 he's 47 but
florence she had no problem standing her
ground i am 24 years old
i do not need you to tell me who i
should and should not love knowing
they're so low-key makes sense they also
kept their breakup under wraps as
florence explains we just felt something
like this would really do us the benefit
of not having millions of people telling
us how happy they are that we're not
together the actress didn't share the
reason behind the split instead she
doubled down and simply explained i
automatically get a lumpy throat when i
talk about it the abuse that you throw
at him
is abuse that you're throwing at me the
stars first kicked off dating rumors in
2019 they met on the set of a short film
zach directed i love being appreciated
to other people who found love behind
the scenes yeah florence's don't worry
darling director olivia wilde and
co-star harry styles
the one thing they ask of us is to stay
here
where it's safe the trailer is steamy to
say the least fans honing in on this
sexy scene between harry and florence's
characters
we are not going backwards we're pushing
forward florence acknowledges the nature
of hiring the most famous pop star in
the world you're going to have
conversations like that but when it
comes to those intimate scenes florence
insists it's not why we do it it's not
why i'm in this industry this movie is
bigger and better than that and the
people who made it are bigger and better
than that
our life together
we could lose this
but we did get a little more insight
from her scene partner you fell in love
on a movie i had a wonderful experience
being directed by olivia i think there
is something that obviously like acting
is kind of very uncomfortable at times i
think you have to you have to trust a
lot requires a lot of trust if you want
to give everything and i think being
able to trust your director is a gift
yeah harry's gf olivia was behind the
camera for his first on-camera sex
scenes how awkward was it for you to do
love scenes and don't worry darling
you've got a couple right it does feel
vulnerable i think like you know i'd
never kissed anyone on camera before and
it felt like giving a part of myself
away in some way because you know you do
it and then you feel like people know
how i kiss or something like it just
feels kind of incredibly vulnerable
[Music]